so let's talk about kinetic energy again
remember when we have the van object
moving with speed V we define the
kinetic energy of the object as a scalar
quantity one-half MV squared this is
scalar and what's very important to
realize it is reference frame dependent
because the velocity of the object
depends on what reference frame were in
now one thing to keep in mind is that
remember our definition of scalar
product a dot B is the magnitude of a
magnitude of B times cosine of theta so
a vector dotted into itself is just the
magnitude of a squared which we can just
write as a squared because the angle is
zero so here we have a V squared so the
dot product BV B squared enables us to
write kinetic energy as one-half M V dot
V and we see our first example of a
scalar product describing a physical
quantity now if we had a coordinate
system where we wrote V as VX I hat plus
V Y J hat plus VZ k hat and we took the
dot product of that vector with itself
then we just know that it's the square
of the components and so in a Cartesian
system we can now say that the kinetic
energy is one-half M be x squared plus
dy squared plus DZ squared because
that's the velocity squared so there's a
simple way to express abstractly the
kinetic energy as a dot product and
explicitly in a coordinate system as the
sum of the squares of the components of
the velocity